most of the stories for this video are
from the book a fire cannot kill a
dragon which is a collection of
interviews behind the scenes of game of
thrones and i also looked at other
miscellaneous articles as a disclaimer
since i'm going to be focusing on a lot
of bad things that happened on set that
doesn't mean that every day it was a
miserable time for the crew so with that
out of the way let's start with any
injuries or harm that came to the crew
and actors
since i put septonella getting
waterboarded in the thumbnail we can
start with that and jump around to other
stories afterwards to preface the scene
cersei destroys the great sept and
captures septo nella for this scene
surprisingly and shockingly enough the
mountain was supposed to rape unnella
according to hannah whitingham who plays
the character which sounds like one of
the worst scenes that could have
possibly have happened but instead they
opted to torture ella by waterboarding
her with wine and fun fact hannah wasn't
even told about this change until she
was in costume and lying down on the
stone slab david and dan walk up to her
saying look the script said cersei
empties the remainder of her glass of
red wine into an ella's face to wake her
up but fans are going to be expecting
more brutality towards unella so it
needs to be a full karafee of wine which
has a pretty mess-up change to make the
day of shooting hannah details the
events we then spent the whole day with
me being waterboarded i'm not
exaggerating when i say that other than
childbirth it was the worst day of my
life
they then proceeded to do that for seven
to eight hours and after the horror deal
was done she had bruises all over her
body and lost her voice from screaming
so basically she got tortured all day
under the guise of acting all so that
david and dan can get a quote-unquote
realistic scene depicting torture which
is weird because you can easily execute
torture scenes in numerous different
ways that don't put the actors health
and well-being in danger
going all the way back to season 1 poor
old hodor endured a back injury
christian narn says i got a back injury
that season i'm probably going to have
for the rest of my life my first day was
the scene where tyrion gives bran the
plans for the saddle they had me carry
isaac up and down the hall 74 times
probably halfway through that my back
had given up the fact that they had to
do that 74 times is absolutely insane
and i don't even know how the first
season had the budget to do the scene
that many times let alone the fact that
the shot where he walks in was very
brief so that seems absurdly unnecessary
christian arne continues i was afraid to
say no it was my first day on set so i
couldn't not do this it's my own fault
for not being honest you wanted to
appear bulletproof
so even though it's partially
christian's fault it's so unreasonable
to want the actor to do that that many
times and he could be over exaggerating
about carrying bran 74 times but he did
give a specific number and got injured
for it
for the scene where tyrion catelyn and
braun are riding up to the veil with a
cliff next to them an actor in a suit of
armor almost got thrown off the cliff by
his horse peter dinklage says we shot
one scene on horseback on the side of a
cliff during a serious windstorm the
horses were very nervous one guy was
thrown from the horse just literally a
couple feet away from the edge of the
cliff he then sat there motionless and
the entire crew thought the man was dead
until finally he moved a couple fingers
after that moment michelle fairly
recounts peter even asking if the horses
were trained peter also says so that was
a bit difficult in terms of like life
and death
for another big horror story that you
may have heard of is that emilia clarke
suffered from a brain hemorrhage after
season one she went through surgery and
afterwards she had trouble even
remembering her own name but regardless
just a few weeks later she went back to
filming and to add on to that the doctor
told her that there was a second growth
on her brain that could pop at any time
emilia said it was crazy intense we were
in the desert in a quarry in like 90
degree heat and i had the consistent
fear that i was going to have another
brain hemorrhage i spent a lot of time
just being like am i going to die is
that going to happen on set because that
would be really inconvenient
she was also heavily fatigued during
this period and even needed an air
conditioning car on set so the fact that
emilia was able to endure all of this
while delivering reams of dothraki and
blistering heat is crazily impressive
and i admire her so much
for a few small stories that i'll bang
out quickly the king's landing set for
the iron throne room was ironically
really cold and one of the handmade
actors wearing a toga pass out from
being so cold which is ironic given that
king's landing is supposed to be pretty
warm then in season 3 during the scene
where jaime lannister is in the mud
getting beaten up by lock nikolaj coster
waldo had one of his ribs broken nikolaj
though wasn't that upset about it
because it was an honest mistake and it
was just a misjudged kick
then there's also the time where david
and dan put a baby on a real block of
freezing ice when asked why they
couldn't have just used fake ice they
said fake ice and close up just never
looks real despite them barely putting
any emphasis on the ice since it was
briefly shown in like two shots then as
you know in the scene the night king has
to interact with the baby and touch him
thus making the baby scream on set and
david and dan realized they were
traumatizing the baby after that david
and damn rudely insisted on seeing the
baby's penis to prove that the baby was
a boy which was both really weird and
made the mother uncomfortable i don't
know why david and dan would want that
so much when it was told to us the scene
prior that the baby was a boy so you
don't need to show his privates moving
over to the battle of the bastards liam
cunningham who plays davos seaworth
almost got decapitated by a russian
crane arm while he was on his horse he
says the horse wanted to play with its
mates and ride off he jumped two feet to
the left and the camera went straight
over where my head was i could have been
decapitated but i ducked the crew were
horrified but luckily he wasn't injured
there was really no one at fault in the
situation since horses can be
unpredictable since we're on season six
sophie turner who plays sansa stark was
told not to wash her hair for long
filming periods since she's supposed to
look dirtier given that she doesn't have
access to a castle she said it is the
most amazing feeling to have a shower
after you go a week and you have snow
and mud and horseshits and all these
disgusting things in your hair to me it
seems like overkill to force your actor
into bad hygiene when you can easily
fake that with makeup and wigs but
sophie turner didn't seem that upset
about the situation moving on though
since that isn't too crazy during the
scene where lancel lannister chases a
kid into the catacombs during the trial
of the seven eugene michael simon who
plays lancel was forced to crawl through
batshits and start bats down there also
keep in mind that his spinal cord was
severed so he was only allowed to crawl
with his arms and upper body for the
entire duration of filming by the end i
was so exhausted and i was literally
frothing at the mouth and the ground was
covered in blood [ __ ] sweat and a few
tears that doesn't seem too bad but
there's an additional thing that happens
that pushes this occurrence over the
edge a bit they put petroleum on top of
the wildfire when the fire went off it
burned off my eyebrows and i could smell
my own burnt hair i just feel bad for
the poor guy since this was probably his
final scene along with hannah who plays
septo nella moving on to something
bigger for the action set piece where
euron greyjoy ambushes yara and theon's
fleet the entire sequence was filmed
pretty chaotically it's detailed that
the ship was on a rig with big water
cannon shooting massive swaths of water
at the actors on top of fire getting
shot out as well obara's stunt double
even had her wig caught on fire and to
add on to all of this the floor was made
out of unstable balsa wood jessica
henwick who plays one of the sand snakes
said at least three crew members fell
through the floor because some of it was
balsa wood so you could smash through it
but it wasn't marked off so occasionally
you would just hear a yelp as another
crew member fell through which to me is
pretty wild and seems like some kind of
safety violation so with all that in
mind the actors were also required to
fight viscerally and were even
criticized for not having enough energy
gemma wellin who played yara greyjoy was
hospitalized during the fight sequence
although there aren't any details as to
why she was hospitalized it could really
have been a number of things at this
rates also in this sequence jessica
henwick gets choked to death with a whip
for her death scene and it did not go
smoothly according to her she said there
was an accident where pillow almost
freaking choked me out with my own whip
then they were shoving me onto a
forklift and hoisting me up there they
wanted to tie me there and put pressure
around my neck as soon as they put me on
it i was like get it off get it off get
it off so yeah that entire sequence did
not go very well
while filming beyond the wall rory
mccann who plays sandra clegane had to
carry a real person on his shoulders
that played a captive white and at one
point he fell down and hurt his leg rory
says i had this guy on my shoulder for
days and days it didn't work with a
dummy so i had to carry a real guy and
we had to run and run which i feel
really bad for him because a lot of the
shots where he's running he's generally
in the background or there isn't a lot
of focus being put on him so it doesn't
seem like they needed to have a real
person be on his shoulders for most of
that time and if you really did just
make it a real person during the
close-ups
for this story it'll make any guys
watching very uneasy but kid
harrington's right tesco got caught on
the dragon rig when there was a scene
where he almost falls off in the first
episode kit says my right ball got
trapped and didn't have time to say stop
and i was being swung around so that's
not exactly what you envision when
riding a dragon
next let's get into the battle of
winterfell and how crazy this entire
shoot was
if anyone doesn't know the battle of
winterfell was an 11 week night shoot
outside in extremely cold temperatures
along with it being windy everyone
involved said it was one of the hardest
experiences they've ever gone through
and was a massive endurance test but
i'll layer on some extra spicy events
that made the sequence even harder to
shoot so to start the production was hit
by two polar vortex storms that
drastically reduced the temperatures one
scene in which sir joy was defending
daenerys it was impossible to shoot
because they couldn't lay a trebuchet in
the background on fire because the gas
fire bars were impossible to light from
how cold it was also if it wasn't hard
enough they shot episode 4
simultaneously during the filming of the
long nights because episode 4 shared
similar sets in winterfell so they opted
to shoot episode 4 scenes during the day
in episode 3 scenes during the night
this led to many essential crew members
working on both the day and night shoots
some crew members were even clocking in
40 000 steps on the pedometers which
roughly equates to 20 miles a day then
for any scene that wasn't filmed outside
during the battle sequence and was
instead filmed in studio the filmmakers
had to recreate the fog of war effect
inside which entailed using real smoke
burning paraffin and fish oil crew
members were breathing it in and one
person had to go to the hospital for
having an asthma attack and other people
were coughing up fish wax on top of
everyone having red eyes from all the
smoke then people were also getting an
intense flu and the producers were using
the motion capture stage as an infirmary
of sorts emilia clarke even got sick
stating everybody in the room was effed
i was incredibly ill on the back of the
dragon then the dragon started to
malfunction a bit and you just try to
hold on then lastly i was saving the
worst thing that happened on set which
was a major injury from the sun actress
named casey michaels where she suffered
a serious fracture dislocation to her
left ankle the stunt was performed when
whites were falling off a ridge into the
winterfell courtyard and this required
multiple sun people to fall into the
same set of cardboard boxes casey claims
that the cardboard boxes were pressed in
from the people falling on them before
her which led to her injury meanwhile
the production company claims that she
fell vertically which was the reason why
she got the injury and this isn't some
smaller deal this lady can barely walk
and carry out ordinary activities and
because of this she's suing the
production company for five million
dollars and it's currently unresolved
but yeah these were all the major
reported incidents i could find on the
battle of winterfell
there are some other behind the scenes
horror stories like the first version of
the pilot that had to be mostly re-shot
but two other channels made big
encompassing videos on that that went
into depth so i don't want to make
anything that's overly redundant in that
area there's also some other brief
problems like how the episode blackwater
lost its initial director just a few
weeks before filming and kit harrington
having to film scenes in season 3 with a
broken ankle but to cap off this video
david and dan were notorious for
carrying out some big pranks on their
cast members primarily in the form of
fake scripts there are quite a few of
these instances but two stand out to me
that i want to mention one of these
occurrences happened to kit harrington
in season 1 where he fights a white for
the first time to save dior mormonts
david and dan wrote the scene where
instead of jon burning his hand when
picking up the torch he instead catches
his hair on fire and it all burns away
leaving a bald jon snow with major
scarring all over his face weiss told
kid harrington that hbo were worried
that jon snow's storyline was too harry
potter and they wanted to do something
to make it darker the messed up thing to
me is that david and dan ran with this
joke all the way up until filming the
scene making it to where they made kit
believe he would be playing a disfigured
character for the rest of the show and
he would be bound to a makeup chair for
many hours
luckily though kit was a good sport
about it but the same couldn't be said
about liam cunningham who plays davos
for this instance david benioff wanted
davos to have a crush on missandei when
they first met and liam was not happy
liam said i fought them i'm not effing
doing it it's the only thing i ever
stood up to them on the woman is a
goddess but with davos's history with
leona mormont and shireen you can't have
him getting the hots for a young woman
he then went on to say he wasn't 100
sure if david and dan were actually
kidding and i love that he was genuinely
uncertain about that fact kind of
alluding to their incompetence at
writing but if they were being serious
then that would have been atrocious so
thank god liam stood up to them on that
issue liam further says you're not
undoing my hard work engendering the
sympathy of the audience to have him be
a perv so from this air of doubt
established between fake script pranks
and actors genuinely not being sure if
the scripts were real most actors
thought the season 8 scripts were fake
since these stories are a bit more
popular i'll run through a few quickly
for isaac hempstead wright who plays
bran he legitimately thought it was a
joke that he became the king and maisie
williams initially disagreed with her
character getting the final blow on the
night king along with those facts the
season 8 scripts essentially gave emilia
clarke an existential crisis because the
characters she idolized suddenly turned
into a villain which even she didn't see
coming emilia said i cried when they
read the scripts it was an effing
struggle i left the house and took my
keys and phone and walked back with
blisters on my feet because i walked for
hours conwath hill plays varys also
famously did not like the season 8
scripts he says at the time nothing
could console me i kept thinking what
did i do wrong you couldn't help the
feeling that you failed in some way that
you hadn't lived up to the expectation
that you didn't know about
he also admitted after this that he was
okay now but he did say that his
character dropped off a bit in terms of
quality overall these are the main
findings i've found through the book
fire cannot kill a dragon and other
sources and there are other minor
problems that i skipped over that i
don't think are really worth featuring
thank you for watching and if you're at
all interested in the making of game of
thrones then check out fire cannot kill
a dragon